[Music]
this morning in our saturday session
rock and roll hall of famer david byrne
he rose to prominence in the mid-1980s
with his band talking heads
for his 2018 album american utopia burn
launched a groundbreaking world tour
which has now become a hit broadway show
we'll bring you special performances in
just a moment but first our anthony
mason talked with byrne about the show
and its many challenges
my name is david byrne
david byrne's broadway show american
utopia began as a concert he toured
around the world
it's kind of a big leap to go to
broadway for me it was
a leap and a risk to go to broadway but
i thought oh no there's also this
opportunity to try something new with it
that i've never ever done before
how did i get here
but american utopia is now in its second
broadway run
the former talking heads front man
[Music]
leads a 12-piece marching band able to
roam the stage wirelessly
you've said
in effect you were trying to democratize
the stage
once you got
have everybody mobile on the stage and
every that anybody can move anywhere
there's no front and back anymore what's
in the front keeps changing all the time
visually it's incredibly exciting to
watch
and it's kind of amazing it's just
people
[Music]
you didn't get just get good reviews you
get like great reviews so i generally
don't read the reviews yes but
occasionally i get sent some of those
little quotes
whoa
people are liking this
how does that feel it's pretty nice
at 69 byrne is performing six shows a
week the broadway schedule is pretty
brutal
yep yep
how you doing i'm doing okay but
i'm singing every song you're not only
singing every song but you're dancing
through and dancing
[Music]
so burns ought the council of another
broadway star if so my friends
currently playing in the music man down
the street i met hugh jackman once
so i reached out to him because he
is the only
broadway performer
that i could remember
who had done a show where he sang every
song so i said how can i do this what do
i need to know yeah
what did he say
he said
don't go hang out with your friends
after that is like for your voice that's
like doing another show right there yeah
and you shouldn't do that he also said
on two show days don't take a nap
why he said because then your voice and
your body and everything kind of goes
back down to
ground zero inviting everyone over
inclusion
not even the omicron outbreak over the
holidays could slow burn down
it missed me somehow but it got half the
band at one point were in quarantine
well some of the crew members using all
their understudies they stayed open with
a stripped-down show
whatever it takes to get by yeah yeah
it's kind of the show must go on even if
it's not exactly the same show
the coronavirus did shut burned down in
one way i wasn't able to write songs you
weren't doing the kind of depth the
depth of the pandemic why do you think i
thought i have not been able to process
this
but he found another outlet how do these
start for you
drawing
they definitely start from an idea yeah
they definitely start from an idea they
don't start from just like doodling
doodling or brush strokes or whatever it
might be no it's definitely an idea and
sometimes i just sketch it like on a
napkin or
scrap of paper dozens of whimsical
sketches that he did for his website
reasons to be cheerful
are now on exhibition at new york's pace
gallery they include a head in the shape
of a house
well
during the pandemic our house kind of in
a way became our head yes we had to live
in that head yeah
that's the truth
got kind of crowded in there too i like
the hot bread delivery
[Laughter]
then there's this sketch titled the
cheese stands alone
during the pandemic lots of us had
things in our refrigerators yes
sometimes for longer than they should
have been
after i'd done quite a lot of them i
realized
i guess i've found a way to
express
in my own way
what we're all going through at this
moment yeah is music therapeutic for you
in that way somehow uh music is
therapeutic for me in a different way
it's physically therapeutic to
to sing yeah whether it's on stage or
just singing at home yeah it's a really
kind of cathartic
experience
[Music]
and that means the whole thing of
working with other people music is very
collaborative you really
form this little team this little tribe
this little community it's it's a utopia
in a way in a little way yeah
when byrne returned to the stage after
covid closed broadway
he introduced his entire tribe
stage crew creative team producers
understudies
and found he wasn't the only one who'd
changed there's a kind of feeling of
relief in celebration that i sense in
the audience now